welcome to this video playing Super Puma
Super Puma from the US played him once
before a draw so besides some relatively
low writing besides rating despite the
rating I need to be gorgeous only 97
okay let's just prevent hmm that's an
interesting move yeah should I should
had damaged structure or not yeah come
on let's do that Queenie too young let's
let's start with this move I am upset go
faster poem but of course is structures
just dumb down terrible
hmm okay I prevent my deform it's
probably worth it 94 or not yeah also be
sure before was possible of course yeah
this looks like in a position worldwide
as compensation for porn but it's not
clear that that is actually better the
diets are looking nice but how do I
actually rather make any any progress in
this position that's not easy I don't
have any porn breaks left this is the
main problem and four is no more fire
for a firm little know things to do yeah
that's really surprising yeah h6 amazing
okay well Knight f6 can check why not
I'm just started that you played this so
quickly giving away this this poem hmm
yeah should it take obvious should be
three the bishop on this happiness not
exactly great but if I retreat maybe all
the way back to Savannah this is
actually the right one and then we
should be too
yeah or queen G for this kind of move
that is better taking was too simplistic
at least that's what I think I mean I
could be wrong mm-hmm okay yeah f2 f2 is
of course bit sensitive and Bishop 3
hmm this isn't so clear what the heck
I cannot believe this nonsense Bishop f3
I have no good move against that don't
tell me that this is the case they are
nobody to what seems like a big brother
yeah I hope hopefully it is it isn't
complete crap yeah may I should have
just taken g7 and swollen and just
exchange stuff it's probably much easier
much easier to play
hmm Jim I'm not showing it all about all
of this yeah couldn't do it couldn't
have played Bishop a three instead of
taking on c1 you for maybe
yeah let's get get out of this out of
this in stable position on d3
miru p1 Bishop g2 or something it's
really a bit shaky maybe 22 I should
have gone to be tuned in the first place
much easier wow this is really
absolutely awful technical player should
have been over long ago okay and now
it's finding good moves this is always
so curious yeah route 87 m can I have no
way to defend that I can't believe it
that's absolutely no way to defend this
check check check check check made or
deform checkmate yeah yeah I really
should be shot for this game what the
[ __ ] sorry I what what what what the
heck did i do there I mean everything
wins except what I playa I should just
take it I mean this is just completely
simple easy and winning yeah he's got no
pawn structure whatsoever and no play I
mean ah no one I want to play more
precisely and this here you can just
play Bishop e3 it's just I just ah it's
just fun awful just so awful yeah yeah
yeah of course Bishop e3 is much
stronger and here I'm better again I
think but it's already it's already Oh
already difficult yeah Computers wants
to play a five yeah I probably shouldn't
exchange and he has just lost him it
just lost I thought okay well let's add
let's protect this but rook f7 is just
strong yeah this is really the the
chesire equivalent of a suicide ritual
what the heck wow this was terrible I
think I lost about 25 rating points for
that and they really should take more
maybe I should message one of the admins
as I can take away some more points
Howard otic is it not to take I mean
this is so simple and also so easy i
mean i saw this but I thought the
the bishop on g7 is not a good piece but
of course there's Bishop a 3 it's just
so simple yeah yeah come on thanks for
watching anyway